il est l'un des plus ardents défenseurs
de la communauté noire
le réalisateur spike lee c'est plus de
35 ans de carrière et de coups de gueule
à la télévision le peuple noir était le
premier peuple sur terre l'afrique est
le berceau de la civilisation
on doit apprendre notre histoire qui
nous a été volé ses coups de gueule sont
nombreux premier exemple en 1986 au
festival de cannes
la raison steven spielberg vient de
réaliser la couleur pourpre l'histoire
d'une jeune femme noire aux etats-unis
au début du 20e siècle
je ne croyais pas au début que spielberg
et réalisé ce film ça m'a carrément
choqué face à yves mourousi spike lee
s'insurge un film sur la condition des
noirs
réalisé par un blanc ça ne plaît pas du
tout aux jeunes réalisateurs et il le
fait savoir
pas vraiment content de soi qu'on n'a
pas besoin nous autres noire d'abord une
définition de notre condition par un
blanc d'hollywood
c'est en plus tard en 1993 sortie de
malcom x biopic centré sur le célèbre
défenseur des droits afro américains
selon son réalisateur
la situation des noirs dans les années
90 n'est pas si éloignée de celle des
années 60 à l'époque de violentes
émeutes raciales vient d'embraser les
états unis le temps simplement un miroir
à la société américaine voilà ce à quoi
elle ressemble ça ne veut pas dire que
cela ne changera jamais je ne suis pas
pessimiste je suis plutôt optimiste je
suis avance ou réalise il ne suffit pas
que blanc et noirs
chante we are the world main dans la
main pour que tout aille bien
[Musique]
après malcom x miracle à santa anna
sorti en 2008
dans ce film spike lee a voulu rendre
hommage à une population oubliée celle
des afro américains ayant servi lors de
la seconde guerre mondiale j'ai fait ce
film parce que jean récurrents les films
d'hollywood sur la seconde guerre
mondiale
sauf que le rôle d'un million neuf cent
mille noir comme celui de nombreuses
femmes qui sont morts pour l'amérique
n'ont jamais été cité au but dix ans
plus tard en 2018
nouvelle prise de position spectacle
vient de réaliser
black lantsman l'histoire d'un policier
noir infiltrés au sein du cucs clan dans
les années 70 là encore selon lui le
film est un reflet de la société
américaine moderne
on voulait absolument que le film
résonne avec ce qui se passe en amérique
aujourd'hui au tijd il y a des petites
phrases america first pour que chacun
prenne conscience du danger qui guette
c'est en 2021
spike lee est à l'honneur pour la
soixante quatorzième édition du festival
de cannes
il est le premier réalisateur noir à
devenir président du jury
[Musique]